a joint CBS News Reuters investigation
discovered new evidence of potential
fraud inside the military's privatized
housing program where some military
families lived with roaches and black
mold a former insider at Lackland Air
Force Base in Texas describes to us the
practices of falsifying reports in order
for a housing contractor to qualify for
big bonuses these allegations are
similar to practices at an Oklahoma base
that we investigated back in June while
more vilafranca is in Dallas for us Omar
good morning disturbing stuff here what
else did you find well a former employee
at Balfour Beatty communities told us
that work issues would take days
sometimes even weeks to fix if they were
fixed at all and on paper everything was
above board but she said the pressure to
falsify records came from management I
told him I said this is lying it's not
right for nearly five years
Teresa Anderson answered maintenance
calls for Balfour Beatty Communities at
Lackland Air Force Base in San Antonio
you had over 1,000 homes that you were
responsible for did you have enough
staff to cover that no we were only
allowed to have nine technicians how is
that physically possible it's not as
work orders piled up wait times grew yet
emails reviewed by CBS News reveal
instructions from Anderson supervisors
that completion times need to be
adjusted to ensure that records showed
over 95% of work orders were resolved on
time did it ever dip below 95 percent it
was always it below that always by
reporting a high on-time completion rate
Balfour Beatty remained eligible for big
bonuses worth more than two million
dollars over the last ten years at
Lackland alone the bonuses are paid from
servicemembers paychecks kept telling
him we can't be closing out work orders
that aren't complete did you ever think
of quitting yeah
why didn't you because I needed the
money
Anderson says she felt pressure from
Community Managers Stacey Nelson who
wrote in one exchange from 2016 it's not
only me on the line but my boss and her
boss she then ordered Anderson and
others to close out maintenance requests
today adding I don't care what it takes
but email show orders to fudge the
numbers came from Nelson superiors and
she described a Reuters depressor she
was under you either make these numbers
match so we can get the incentive fees
or you may not have a job tomorrow she
said in response to questions from
Reuters and CBS News Balfour Beatty said
they have ordered an investigation into
fraud allegations and an independent
accounting review the company said both
Nelson and Anderson were fired in 2016
for performance related issues and they
are conducting a comprehensive review of
work order practices across its army and
navy bases this Lackland Air Force Base
the worst place you lived yes and that's
just my point
Roxanne Rowland's husband is a weapons
instructor in the Air Force her family
lived on four different military bases
before moving to Lackland in June how
soon were you seeing roaches in your
home that night the same day the same
day what was your tipping point I opened
the cabinet under the kitchen sink there
was black mold Assistant Secretary of
the Air Force John Henderson told CBS
News his office is referring to
allegations of misconduct at Lackland
fir investigation and warned of formal
action unless there's prompt and
substantial improvement from Balfour
Beatty
when you hear about falsification of
records what's your reaction knowing
that you're living in one of these homes
discussed how do you sleep at night did
you feel bad about doing this having to
do this yeah it wasn't right it was to
me it's not taking care of the residents
who were in this military world where
they're going out and fighting for us
after the first CBS News Reuters
investigation the Air Force suspended
all bonus fees for all their bases where
balfour beatty operates and right now
the Air Force is investigating
allegations of record-keeping fraud at
at least five bases tony omar thank you
very much that's a powerful
investigation there is no questions
nobody ever wants to hear yep house um
did you see roaches I'd say what I've
seen some roaches in one night in an
apartment in New York we don't she don't
she don't exactly right